today we're talking about data fusion
new cloud certifications and Google
cloud next 2020 I'm mark merchandani and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news cloud
data Fusion is our fully managed data
integration service that simplifies how
you authenticate monitor and protect
your data and we've just released new
beta features such as support for VP C
service controls check the blog for an
overview of the built-in features
working to keep your data safe last
September we announced improvements to
the cloud build github app making it
easier for developers to trigger builds
on specific branches pull requests or
tags we're happy to announce that those
features are all now generally available
go try them out for 2020 we've got two
new certification programs the Google
cloud certified fellow is an
invitation-only certification program
for technical leaders designing
enterprise solutions with anthos through
a series of assessments and labs the
program will identify experts who can
effectively lead organizations through
frictionless hybrid multi cloud adoption
and the professional cloud devops
engineer certification enables cloud
professionals to demonstrate their
expertise and development operations and
service reliability to employers check
them out if you're looking to add more
certifications to add to your collection
we just announced the dates for Google
cloud next 2020 during this in San
Francisco or online April 6 through
April 8th for some Google cloud magic
registration is now open if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link have
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you